je vous remercie madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre monsieur le
Président de la Rada à travers vous
c'est le plus craignant que je souhaite
saluer vous qui combattez avec courage
avec force avec détermination l'invasion
russe face à vous le mythe de la
puissance russe c'était de cholé je
tiens au nom du groupe écologiste à vous
assurer de notre soutien et de notre
solidarité dans ce combat l'Ukraine
défend nos valeurs la liberté et la
démocratie je sais que nous les
partageons c'est l'honneur de la France
d'avoir pu accueillir celles et ceux qui
ont été arrachés alors maison à leur
famille et à leurs amis la Russie de
Vladimir Poutine espérer isoler
l'Ukraine de l'Europe elle nous a fait
nous rapprocher nous peuvent n'ont
jamais été aussi liés et demain
l'Ukraine une Ukraine qui aura retrouvé
son intégrité territoriale sera
pleinement membre de l'Union européenne
face au retour de la guerre l'Union
européenne n'a pas failli des sanctions
étaient prises la solidarité
internationale européenne et française
s'est organisée pour finir pour fournir
de l'aide d'humanitaire et du matériel
militaire cette solidarité est
indispensable à la victoire la stratégie
de la Russie et de privé l'Ukraine et
les ukrainien de tout la Russie déprime
d’énergie elle est prise de soin elle
éprive d'eau potable et elle veut
également les priver d'avenir car c'est
un lieu commun mais c'est tellement vrai
qu'il faut le rappeler la guerre brise
des vies c'est tout un pub qui subit les
bombardements les tortures les viols et
la mort la guerre empoisonne les terres
ainsi la dispersion de munitions et
l'enfouissement de mines sur plus de 250
km² mais en danger la vie des Ukrainiens
et empoisonne les sols les plus fertiles
d'Europe la guerre saccage un pays et
son patrimoine 200 000 hectares de forêt
ont brûlé 900 zones naturelles protégées
ont été touchés un tiers des espaces
protégés ont été abîmés enfin cette
guerre mais l'Europe en danger les
infrastructures nucléaires ukrainiennes
sont des cibles répétées devenu un
espace de conflit leur sécurité n'est
jamais complètement garantie le
nucléaire est ainsi un danger pour
l'Ukraine et pour l'Europe le nucléaire
est également une arme d'influence dans
un monde incertain l'indépendance et
notamment l'indépendance énergétique est
cruciale pendant des années nous avons
fait de Poutine un partenaire politique
dans nos relations internationales en
raison de nos dépendances aux énergies
fossiles aujourd'hui l'Union l'uranium
russe peut toujours être un outil de
centrage de la part de la Russie par
l'intermédiaire de l'entreprise rosatum
nous devons mettre un terme à tout ce
qui nous contraint à la dépendance
envers la Russie madame la Première
ministre alors comment comptez-vous
libérer la France de ce levier
d'influence russe alors que l'uranium a
été exclu de l'embargo décédé à
l'encontre de la Russie comptez-vous
enfin émancipez la France de ces
fournisseurs d'uranium autoritaires
[Applaudissements]